and so we saw a lot of your responses a
lot of people had a lot to say in
regards to the video we made about
uh the banning of trump on social media
platforms and tick tock
and tick tock that's right and i thought
it'd be a good idea for us to kind of go
through some of the responses and just
have
a good conversation people said to me
well about your solution is terrible
getting the government involved
it sounds like a terrible idea excuse me
the government's involved in every facet
of your life
you live in a building thank god there's
building regulations
because you know what if they were
building your house without any
regulations you know what they would do
they would cut
corners right people think like people
have this really potato capitalistic
libertarian viewers like
the free market will handle no people
will cheat you if there was no
regulations the food that you would
receive
would have issues yo listen if contract
workers people worked in construction
could cut corners bro
do you know how many accidents we would
have like in sri lanka when those
buildings come down on all those kids at
schools like yes they would
you mean to tell me that there are some
people that would cut corners for money
and when you guys talk about like why
don't you make your own platform i don't
think you guys really understand
how monopolies work you can't just beat
a monopoly when they own the market they
don't allow you to come up they buy you
out
they work with lobbying groups to make
sure that your type of application does
not see the light of day
like apple for example owns 70 of the
podcast market
if they start filtering things out a lot
of podcasts are just going to fall off
the face of the earth
you cannot just defeat monopolies it's
not this thing where if you come up with
a genius idea
gonna take over no and that's why
there's anti-trust laws that exist
they exist because it protects you the
consumer if verizon is working with
every other telecom company right
and they say we're all gonna raise our
price at the same time what are you
gonna do
what are you gonna do you can't do
nothing they're all going to make a
profit because you have to go to them we
have that problem here in canada
you can't fly domestically with any
american airline
european the only people that can fly in
canada are canadian airlines
there's two of them three two and a half
two and a half
okay westjet air canada well air canada
is the big one
westjet porter now here's a fun fact
air canada and westjet's prices pretty
much exactly the same
they price up and they mark up the price
all the time what means
people never travel within the country
because it's too expensive
it's cheaper for me to fly to europe
than it is for me to fly my own country
why because they have a monopoly for the
same amount of time
like it takes about six hours to go to
france it took about six hours to go
to bc it's cheaper for me to go to
france
it cost me it cost me less to go to
italy when it's further down
than to go to the to go to the bc and
these things are government protected
where they've lobbied enough in order to
save themselves so monopolies are a huge
problem
they actually shaft everybody imagine so
when you guys
it bothers me so much when you guys sit
there and you guys are caping for
for corporations as if they're not
shafting everyone i'm like you guys
are are basically rooting for the enemy
you don't even realize it like these
guys don't lean left or right they leave
what's politically
financially good for them money that's
where they lean
period so when i say regulation i don't
mean that we take over
but it would be good to say we work in
the financial sector maybe creating
committees
that explain why people are banned when
it comes to like high profile figures
and they demonstrate it right or
committees that are holding them
accountable making sure that they're
doing these bands evenly across the
political spectrum and not just leaning
one way
one thing that a lot of people said was
um
it wasn't arbitrary there was a very
specific reason
and the reason why i use the word
arbitrary is not because i don't
understand why it was banned in fact
i agree with it the issue i had was that
they chose it at an arbitrary time if
you're saying he violated tos therefore
he deserves to be banned i agree
but let's also not pretend like he
hasn't violated 25
30 times before this is what i mean when
i say it's arbitrary if you have a set
of rules and guidelines
you never enforce it but all of a sudden
you do enforce it
then of course i'm going to say it's
arbitrary because you've allowed this
stuff to happen and perpetually happen
over the course
of four long years and
and it's a great example because for
that person just for that person
there's me many instances so you can't
say like it was another but for
other people it was not applied for
other people that were egregious for
other people that have been strength
transgressing those guidelines and
having they haven't been going with
those
guidelines that it's not done it's not
applied no it's like sometime it is
sometimes it's not like i sometimes
at some point i really thought that
twitter was
just a free forum before because it was
not
it was never never applied i read the
guidelines i know what's acceptable
what's not
and then for some people you decide to
apply it for some other people not
and for the same person at some time
that they do it you don't apply it and
then add some
you you realize oh yeah we should we
should apply it it's weird
yeah and if you actually look at the
tweets i decided to go look at what they
banned him for okay
i wanted to read i'm going to read for
you guys the exact tweets that the
official blog post said they abandoned
for these are the tweets okay
we the 75 million great american
patriots who voted for me america first
and make america great again will have a
giant voice long into the future
they will not be disrespected or treated
unfairly in any way shape or
form that's the first tweet and the
second tweet that they claimed was
bannable
to all those who have asked i will not
be going to the inauguration on joining
january 20th so based off of the context
based off his media appearance
what twitter was saying was these two
tweets in conjunction with everything
he's done
off the platform as well as on we've
decided that he is a threat
now what i will concede is this i felt
like he was dog whistling and he didn't
encourage and partially incite that
that being said what he did on the
actual platform based off of the tweets
that they're banning him for
it's not a thing so so for everyone
saying oh it's just about this no it's
about the amalgamation of all the things
that he's done up until this point
plus this this was the tipping point if
you will
right this was the tipping point now
here's my problem
my problem is not that they banned them
my problem is that they banned it for
something that happened on twitter
and then he was banned from every other
platform be it spotify
be it twitch which he wasn't even using
every platform abandoned
now why does this matter this matters
because let's say
you say something in a tv news network
okay you say i don't think it's a good
idea for men to compete against women in
sports
if you were born a male i don't think
well if
in their terms of service they feel like
that is speech that is unacceptable
and you've set it off platform now they
have the right to ban you
what people also have to realize is like
these kind of ideas that we're now
accepting because
you know listen eileen left so of course
a lot what he says does not agree with
me
i get that but it's not because you're
winning today that you're not going to
be losing tomorrow at the end of the day
corporations and these people they only
care about themselves so just because
you see your views reflected now
trust me at some point they won't be and
then you're going to be like how did we
get here it's because we're allowing all
this stuff to happen
slowly and we're accepting it not only
we're accepting it we're encouraging it
step by step joe tell me how it makes
sense that the taliban has got an
official
twitter the taliban i know
what are you talking about and the and
the problem with all this is i see a lot
of people like especially minority
community like man go go go
but yo listen these kind of laws and
policies are applied against you guys
all the time
take palestinians who are fighting for
their agency within the west bank
they can barely get on twitter in a lot
of situations to say what they think
yep so the downtrodden camp right like
let's say if you're
people abandoned france why because they
said man listen the jewish influence in
this country is important horse
anti-semitism banned yep
that's real here's the fact and then you
have the ayatollah who's saying death to
israel
and he's a lot on twitter make it make
sense for me
does that not like sound like a call to
action considering what's happening in
israel on a regular basis with people
attacking
is it i don't know it's an inconsistency
for me it's just
these rules don't make sense these
platforms have too much influence
people like oh it's social media we used
to exist yeah but
how we used to live it doesn't matter to
how we live today before cars we had
horses
we're not going back this is not going
to turn into brokeback mountain
it's over what nothing
yeah yeah
so when people say that i'm like you
realize that facebook has 2.5 billion
users
do you know what the population of the
world is isn't like six million seven
do you understand that's one platform
2.5
billion users in fact nowadays more
americans get their news from social
media than they get it from anywhere
else
so when you sit there and you're like
it's not that big of a deal it's a huge
deal
most people under 35 don't even own a
television
oh what a television never heard of it
i got a screen you know what i'm saying
so it just blows my mind people
it's not that big it's a huge deal but i
feel like people are too happy about
just being in this dude
and not enough about thinking about
what's the implications of that and why
we're not talking about how we became so
divided
one man cannot divide everybody there
has to be some seeds in your heart
where you feel like you don't identify
with your name people are really just
happy with the end result and not how it
happened yeah that's what's going on
yeah yeah they really
that's what i wanted yeah it's like it's
like it's like it's like if you got pain
from an infection you just take
painkillers
but you haven't taken any antibiotics so
that's pretty much all i got for today's
video tell us what you guys think in the
comments below do you guys agree or
disagree we want to hear your thoughts
on to why
but man stop stop cheering on these
corporations because they're not looking
out for you and you're going to look
stupid in a couple years
all i want to say is that they don't
really care about they don't really care
about you that's crazy
it's super cringe oh my god i'm so happy
these corporations they don't give a
[ __ ] they care about your money though
talking about the benjamin's baby
[Music]
and